Nó ngày 3,5 năm, tông tin từ công an tình đồng này đơn vị đạo
hỏng tất kêu lợt đuổi trà vụ sức hải 3 người trong một gia đình tệ sả đất nhau.
Thưa đó, bị cân lên xí tụng đã thực hiện hình ví phạm tội một mình không có đủ
phạm trong quả trình về an. Cơ quan cây rất đuổi trà khởi tổ bị cân đời với tụng
về cơ tổ, dịt lời, cứ tài sản, về hỏi tệ sản và tăng chữ, vẫn chuyển
sự dụng và một bản chế phép vụ khi quân dụng. Ngoài ra, cơ quan đuổi trà
tình tên nhìn, với văn vật chú phần của này, tình đồng này và phạm qua hủy chú phần chung thành tình tháng
Ngoài ra, cơ lợt đuổi trà trở thấy tụng không có công an việc làm, không có tuy nhập như lại hưởng
tụng lỗi sống xa hoa, tưởng đăng lên phê sống cá nhân thị hình việc đi dù lịch, mô sống xem
một tổ và khối lớn để đi phượt, mô xuống và tưởng đi xanh bánh, tham gia hội xuống xanh, tham gia
các trở trời cảm giác mạnh và các lại đi bảo lực. Tụng từ la sinh viên trường đại học công nghệ
tụng tin, nhưng đã bỏ học giữa trường và tưởng năm hợp lúc mấy một tùng phạm tội chung
các tại sản bị sự an 2,5 tưởng tụng trèo. Với bản tin 3 hưởng tụng lưới lấy đồng và đi có
tình thư sai, tụng đánh này sình ý định thực hiện thành viên giết người, cứ tại sản. Lăng người tưởng dự giới giống
sống xanh và tưởng suyên xanh bánh, nên tùng xa định bản thân sẽ sử dụng xuống để thực hiện
vẻ an, để thực hiện em yêu, tụng bản xem một tổ lấy tiền đặt mô xuống quân dụng cùng bây chăm
1. Bộ hộ đi cạnh, mua mấy cắt sách đen viên, khăn chung đồng, tóc giả, lưỡi cầu, dây dù,
các bạn của nảo, dây dễb để thi đổi hình dạ, nhằm chân sự phát hiện và đánh lạc rung
chuyến sẽ của các quan chức năng sau khi vẻ an tổ thoát. Theo que có điều tra, kếm lại của tùng là
tình dạ điện nạn nhân dầu có, ở bị lập nơi hệ hở lãnh để vẻ an, sau khi đã chừng bị đe đủ các cầu cụ,
phương tệ nơi trên, tụng đi khảo sát tình trọn con mùi và đi điều vẻ an. Đâu thằng tạng năm
như vụ sọng ăn làm, tùng phát hiện cơ sở tùng mua nông sản khi hạnh tệ sả đất nhau có nhà cửa khăn sàng,
trong nhà có nhiều tệ sản và ở một mình như hệ hở lãnh, nên tùng đã nhiều lần đến khảo sát,
năm so sấu với xí sống, cứ lực xí hoạt của gia đình. Đặc biển đứa bàn,
sau định hưởng tình công gây an và tổ thoát, sau khi nghiên cứu xác định gió một kiêu,
phương an thì tụng cứ định ra tay về an. Ngay mua tắng nguyện năm hành hình khu trong ăn làm,
tùng suốt phát tụng nguyện ở tại phương phức lắm, bình phức ủc mục đình được khiến sẽ mấy đi đến bệnh viện thành tâm,
phương lắm mình tình đông này và người sẽ tại đây. Rồi đóng xe khách đi đa lạch,
tự nơi lực tụng đỏng xe quay về gá tương dầu dễ thị xuống, đóng xe khách đi đến hát tự ám tạng,
đóng xe luôn đi tới trước con xuy tiến, đóng xe biết đi bệnh xe mình đông.
Lúc bệnh dừng hài tháng nguyện năm hành hình khu trong hành lắm, tụng lên xe khách thành công nghĩ đến xả bông bóng,
tụng đỏng xe luôn đi sả đất nhau. Cách nhà nạn nhân khoảng 2 kêu mát tụng xuy xe đi bộ trở lâu cao xù tơi tí cần cơ xờ tụng mua đông xảnh thi này.
Mỗi lần thế đổi phương tệ trên đường dưới chuyện thì tụng đều thế đổi cho phục trinh người với lứt đổi tóc giả,
mũ cết lưới trái, đào khổ chàng chuẩn kiến mặt, trước khi tiếp cận mục tiêu người ám,
tụng thay tòa mộ cho phục đăng mặc tí tụng mặc bộ đồng phục truy giữ trẻ xe bụt tô phật.
Đào kính vọng hộ, mũ bảo hộ, lăng tay, lắp xung bắn tử chính sát, rồi xử dụng móc có móc và cũng các cuộc phần.
Bộ xe dụng kéo dài để dịch phúc định giữ vỏ nhé nạn nhân, khi phát hiện ra định nạn nhân tập trung ăn tối thị tụng đứng tự biệt lâu cao xù đối dịch.
Cách kỷ chi cơ nạn nhân 3 mấy mê, xả đặt linh tụng làm chết bà người, mắn nộ mắt cao mera rồi và phòng các kết sát lấy tài sản của ra định nạn nhân và tổ phát.
Chỉ trong năm sau giờ kể từ khi tiếp n涂 tình buạn, lúc mấy bà giờ 3 mê mừng năng tặng nguyện 5 ngày khu trăm 5 mấy lắm.
Cơ quan kể rất đều tra công an tình đồng này đã bắt xử lấy sĩ tụng và tụng rử dữ tụng 1 tăng bật.
Cái sản linh quan buạn, bởi kích tâm hình chương đều tra, làm só, chỉ bắt chị đề đối tự linh quan đề sử linh nghiêm mi.
Trong thời hạn 20 ngày, các quan kể rất đều tra đã bắt xử thêm bà đối tự 1 bàn tụng khi tụng đã sử dụng kể ăn và kết lượng đều tra, đề nghị chỉ tổ các biệt cao.
Cơ quan đều tra, vinh kìm sát in zinh và toán in zinh tình đồng này đã học.
Thống nước sẽ đưa vụ an ra sẽ xử cơ khai trong thống mấy một năm 2019 đề kì thời trên an zil ận và lập lại tình kinh an in chực tự tại đi vừa.